are we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidra your SciFi TV and Movie Channel
I'm here with Katie say hello Katie
hello
Katie oh it's a good joke the old ones
are the classics and
they so I I thought I'd invite you on
Kitty because um I I have to admit I've
um only come across your channel quite
recently but you're a hardcore Star Trek
fan and
um since a couple of videos I've done on
Legacy we we we we came across each
other so I thought we'd have a bit of a
chat about but that's cool that's
perfectly fine awesome um I don't know
if you guys got that I've got a little
bit of a delay on you Katie sorry so if
I talk over you I'm sorry because I
don't know it's because you're so far
away in in America land um I apologize I
it's possibly because my kids are here
and they're playing on the computer and
it's possibly my internet this course
and the the lag but and it could be on
my end as well because my husband is a
uh computer security professional who
works from home so our computers are
always very busy well he he really
should be putting our video in
respons I have
Echo computer stop oh I should probably
unplug mine because it's probably gonna
set mine off at some point but anyway
so before we get into Legacy I'd love to
know sort how you feel about Star Trek
because I've talked a lot about how
there's been a bit of division with the
Star Trek fans particularly the old FS
like me yeah I'm I'm no good with the
division of it um I mean I have
favorites and ones that I would prefer
to watch and I've watched you know
Voyager probably at least 20 times
through no hands down probably the one
I've watched the most but I grew up with
the original series I follow all of them
I just love the Universe of Star Trek
overall yeah I think that's I I think d
space 9 was my
favorite if I if I think I think I loved
um Voyager do you know what I think some
of the best episodes were Voyager and I
think like
Scorpion and episodes like that my God
they were good and serious fin finale
hands down Voyager they actually like
ended the series
well yeah t t&g went out in a bit of a
whimper Deep Space 9 the finale was like
three episodes before the end and then
it sort of fire gods yeah um and that
went out but the the Enterprise finale
let's just pretend that didn't happen um
good like people hate that episode I say
it would be a good like series finale it
was just a bad like series finale you
know I me like a season finale it would
have been quite good um
but voyages was
brilliant was it called Equinox is that
right I always forget I can remember
Equinox was one of the part one part
twos I think that was season three or
yeah season three because scorpion was
at the end of four wasn't it yeah so
yeah Equinox was a whole different
situation yeah I do remember that I do
remember some of the titles but um my
favorite actually episode one of my
favorite episodes ever was Enterprise
and it was um the one with a borg in and
I can our regenerations I love that
episode that's one of those actually go
back and find and watch over and over
again sort of thing um there we go end
game was the finale yeah as soon as you
say it it rings Rings
true so what do you think about the the
new Trek then is there stuff you like
about it stuff you don't like about
it well I think that people are looking
for the classic story and you're not
going to find that as much in these new
ones with the exception of strange new
worlds and I think that that brings more
of a variety of Storytelling types so we
get more fans because you know maybe
they just want the cartoons maybe others
were looking for a a strong female
leader like we had in janway and that's
where Discovery comes in um I think that
if you look around you might not find
that every Star Trek is your favorite
but you're going to find one that you
enjoy even if you are not a treky and so
I love the variety
personally and and that's always secret
hideouts and um Jean roden's kids whose
name is just going out my
head rodeny Jr that's not his
name but he was saying that that that
there's a treky for everyone and I'm
sort of like oh we had TNG and Voyager
in dpace 9 and treky pretty much
universally love them why can't they do
do Star Trek that and because personally
I can't stand Discovery i' I I tried I
really tried um uh I I've I don't think
I've managed to get every time there's a
new season I'm go right damn it I'm
gonna sit I'm gonna watch this and I'm
go and I never get I never get through
it I always just get I just I just don't
like it I don't like the characters I
think they're so forgettable um other
than the chap on I forgotten his name I
want to say siru or
neru
uh that guy yeah suu suu I was I was
pretty close um I've never really
watched it um but I um I but I just love
watching him thinking that poor actor
like that must hurt so much I'm was like
I really sympathize for him um but I I
just really other than the episodes with
um
with Michelle yo and an emperor Empress
the empress um I I just adore those
adored those episodes um I don't I don't
like it but yeah Empress giorio is just
the greatest other than
that don't like
it that's perfectly Fair my um my family
who are the classicists do not care for
it simply because of the change in the
Klingons in the first season and I'm
like if you can get past that okay um we
all had to get past changes in the
Klingons in the
movies and then when Worf steps on the
bridge of the enterprise we all had to
get past that and then we all had to get
past the woman being the captain of a
ship and then we all had to get past
well not in the right order but we all
had to get past a black man being in
command of a station it seems that a lot
of times we as Tres get really upset at
the Star Trek we've been given and then
101 15 years later we adore it so maybe
in
time maybe I have to admit I didn't like
voyages straightway I think I actually
stopped watching it and then I caught it
when um I might have been a bit of a boy
about this um obviously I saw Jerry Ryan
and I thought I might watch that but I
was I was about 21 years old or
something at the time so fair totally
I've grown up a bit since then not a lot
but a little bit um and but then I
adored it and then I went back and
watched it again and actually fair I
think I felt the same way about Deep
Space 9 at the time I didn't really like
it at first but I didn't like TNG at
first I thought it I didn't think it was
very good um but I always think almost
every great show I can ever think of the
first Seasons they're finding their feet
and they've got a lot of story to tell
so it's not maybe it's not maybe
exciting but and you've got to fall in
love with the characters and stuff so it
does take a bit of time to to get into
it um but then Voyager probably did
become my favorite show I just loved it
I think D 9 is is the best overall but
um for me anyway I just love the wars
and stuff but um out of the new stuff
though I it's the animated stuff I love
I I I Adore lower deck and I adore
Prodigy I think it's great I really
really love lower decks
um I have a love hate with with with um
strange new worlds I love an episode
hate an episode love an episode hate an
episode but overall I think the
characters are so good it's it's okay so
even if it's an episode I don't like
particularly the characters are so good
there'll be something there I enjoy sort
of thing yeah other than the musical the
musical can bugger off um but I try to I
try to erase that from my
brain um but uh even though I've tried
to watch it a couple of times since and
every time I just like I know the cake
pop Klingons are coming and I just
can't
but um yeah the first season of
Discovery
no do you say like we have to get over a
black Captain or a female captain or
well who's a commander and all these
things I think that's like Tre stuff the
problem for me was I had issues when
they when they' mess with Cannon so
much um and it's not even they mess with
Canon they made the Klingons look
weird um you know they were strange then
then I do have a bit of a issue with
that I I I think Cannon is something
that should be respected but at the same
time there's still a story to tell you
know so it's like it's okay to fudge but
then sometimes if they just completely
change something I'm like no come
on
um well I I think that like with the
clons with the Gorn with um terites with
pretty much any of the aliens that we
saw 20 30 years or more ago they've
updated the look for the technology in
that we have in makeup now that we
didn't have back then and I think they
just went a little too far with the
Klingons they changed the structure they
still had a I don't want to say human
face but a human face and it was it was
the the brow ridges that was the big
difference and this it became completely
crazy well I
think the makeup was worse that problem
somehow they made
it
the G 100% I
get oh was a little bit but hopefully
your back's back in a sec but yeah I
mean the gone you can't have a plastic
you know a rubber Lizard Head you know
that just wouldn't work um
but um yeah the king onon I just think
that was Alex kurtzman I
just blame Alex kursman for it don't
blame him for everything just just just
that
um so with the new trk then um obviously
Picard season 3 came along and that
really pleased particularly the old
school fans like
me um did I mean because I am a I I
consider myself a treky who fell out of
love a little bit with Star Trek I um I
found Stargate and I sort of it it stole
my heart a little bit um but um
can you can you sort of get why peard
season 3 was so popular with you know
the the FY trekkies like
myself okay I'm sorry we can't hear
you I think probably good if we sort of
drop you out and I'll just waffle for a
minute and and bring you back in if
that's right because sometimes it's just
like a re start is all you need all
right this keeps happening so um let's
just see if it would
think sometimes that's sometimes it's
just that's enough to be honest no she's
going to drop out and come back in a sec
so uh this is two live streams in a row
now that I've had issues with the
internet and actually our mate mic is in
the um audience at the moment and so you
know what I'm talking about you with
your bloody
internet anyway
no actually worse um you might have to
do a restart I'm so sorry might
sometimes you have to restart the
computer it's not streamyard Mike it was
you I've been using streamyard with
other people it was your internet mate
so don't Dy playing the right um let's
have a look um yes K turn it off and on
again fixes everything damn it um let's
have a look at some of the comments
let's let's go back
through
um is your personal Star Trek preference
for a serialized series or an episodic
series that's a bloody good question
actually s a
guy I want a bit of
both I like when you have the ongoing
story arc through a series right and I'm
thinking something like series not not
sci-fi now but series like The
Mentalist or um even like CSI Vegas when
they had like the ongoing story arc
through those are sometimes the best
episodes they were brilliant and you
sort of want that threat that is so big
it needs more than one
episode so that that's that's great
great um but I don't want the discovery
one story I think they're boring um and
and to be honest the threats in
Discovery have been so
ridiculous that it's just
like like the burn what the hell were
they thinking with that so no I don't I
don't think that's great to be honest I
I want to mix I think strange new worlds
does it better but I want more episodes
of strange new worlds I think strange
new worlds would be so much better if
there was like 20 episodes um or even 15
or something and then they could have a
few more a couple more of the ongoing
episodes I actually don't think we've in
a way we haven't really had two seasons
of strange new worlds I say we've had
one season of strange new worlds if you
actually watch it as one
season um it's it's it's quite good you
would you would have that as a season of
Star Trek all day um but as two seasons
I feel a bit ripped off
um but that's just me um at least we had
Star Trek unlike
Stargate yeah well we're still waiting
we got we got it we got it yeah um we
had a bunch of news yesterday bunch of
people have been announced to sort of in
the thing and yeah we get joio back
Michelle yes she's my favorite character
in all of the new trk joio all day um
let's not go quite that far but yeah
okay
um and we're back we're back we're back
hey maybe yes I can hear you you don't
sound like our dude D2 after 20
points so we're good we're good I'd be
under the table after three
so um where were we somebody actually
just asked a question I think it was
really interesting um do you prefer
episodic Star Trek or sort of like the
long star story arc Star
Trek I do love a good story arc because
I will obsessively watch a show never
miss a minute rewatch each episode two
or three times so I I'm good with both
but I do love a good story arc yeah I
just say I think I want a bit of
both for me I like a bit about well in
strange new worlds says it's episodic
but they you know they do put in an arc
the gor were after them the whole first
season and there was more going on the
second season so I think we kind of get
an arc and strange new worlds just not
as obviously as we we do with Discovery
yeah I think so um I was say I I
actually if you think of strange new
worlds with one long season of 20
episodes it feels more like original
sort of Star Trek and as well and that
way I wouldn't get so angry about things
like the musical
episode because um I wouldn't think I
just I just felt like I was a bit ripped
off by it I was like no this is this is
valuable Star Trek real estate don't do
it be do it as a Christmas special don't
do it as the ninth episode in a season
um that's all I had a problem with it
but but um Picard season 3 then so I was
just asking like you know it
was for me that was the only time I've
actually got excited about Star Trek in
a very long time that I was actually
like I got up early on the Thursday
morning when it premiered over here to
watch it um and I haven't done that for
Star Trek for a very long time the first
episode of discover when it came out it
was the first time I was sort of like
Star Trek and then by the end of the
episode I was
like what they do with the cling ones um
but I I I loved it even though certain
episodes of theard season 3 annoyed me
because of Miss silly mistakes and
things but that's just me being like a
bit nitpicky overall freaking loved it
um is it the best of TR that we've had
in the live action for you or is is it
just more brilliant
track I think it was probably the best
especially with the fact that they were
very
respectful of all of the fans and gave
them a little bit here and a little bit
there Easter eggs Galore uh from the
moment where we're panning on uh to
Beverly's ship and we see the the flower
and Jack crusher's case I mean those
were things that were from the Next
Generation and so I think from that
first moment you're like oh okay we know
what we're doing
now yeah
exactly it felt like home didn't it I
have to admit it felt like home and it
had a bit of humor in it stuff as well
and it had a bit of it felt it it felt
like what track should be you know it's
like um that's one thing that I like
don't discover is too serious I like it
to be a bit more sometimes strange new
worlds is too
silly sometimes stupid joke
the um the thing with um Spock and you
know theyve there's this running joke
now about what is your thing and that's
how they left us with Picard season 3
we're going to find out what Seven's
thing is is it you know let's fly which
I hate but or you know engage you know
whatever um and they did that joke with
Spock in the second episode and I was
just like oh it's such a stupid joke and
it was such a long winded joke to get to
the punch line
like um but um yeah I just I just I love
I love Picard season 3 because it was
actually the first two seasons both
started really well and then
disappointed me badly the second season
neutered the and ruined the Borg how do
you ruin the greatest villain one of the
greatest villains ever in SciFi I
just I I will say that I enjoyed the
first season quite a bit um I liked the
play on on you know what do we do with
the artificial life form I really
enjoyed that I I agree with you on the
second season it was an interesting
Adventure I liked the time travel I
don't know why they killed the Borg I
don't know why they completely changed
what they are so I I'm with you on that
yeah everyone saying that I should get
purple hair I'm not sure I it suits I'm
digging the purple hair but I I don't
think I can pull it
off I maintain I will tell you that
is I but I need to get purple here um so
um yeah I just don't understand and the
other thing was that whole series the
second series though if um
jatti
yeah if she have just gone it's me don't
shoot we've got a thing to go sort I'll
explain later the entire series was
completely irrelevant everything that
happened in between was just didn't
matter at all well no because Gera
didn't become part of the queen until
they traveled back in
time yeah but in Star Trek they've
repeatedly so you got two two types of
time
travel Theory so the one is that you've
got like multiple thingies so that if
you change something in in the future
you you create a new future and then you
go along or the other one is that you
when you go travel back in time you
create a completely new timeline so um
so basically one you've got the
grandfather Paradox where if you go back
and kill your granddad you never existed
then you can never go back and kill your
granddad or you've got the you can go
back and kill your granddad and it's
fine because you still exist and you you
just create a new timeline Star Trek
have repeatedly done the
second so they she could have gone it's
fine it's me and it would have been fine
because that that's what they've done in
Star Trek loads of times they didn't
need need to that's that that would have
been fine there's no grandfather Paradox
in Star Trek they've um ignored it years
ago I I disagree because Voyager when
they went back in time that's how the
jerk face I forget his name got
technology and became Rich because of
that crash ship from traveling in
time it it it does weird things I I Star
Trek does what they need to for the
story depending on it but just depend on
what they need for the story sometimes
and then they have like we've painted
ourselves into a corner on this one we
will need to reverse the polarity and
you know the writers are just going we
just need a techno Babble just get data
to say
something we'll be fine but that's all
sci-fi in every
story ration from the time Rift kept us
from experiencing the changes in time or
something like I'll just just reverse
something on my badge
now I'm protected um yeah um or we what
was it the Enterprise D was they were
caught in the Chron chronometric
wake yes yes that's how time travel
Works um and what did the Bor do that
ages
ago brilliant that's my favorite tons I
don't think that's how you spell it but
there tons I've got to love a good
tachon tons tons always cause trouble
so Legacy and that's why we're here
let's be honest um do you want to tell
tell us a bit about the because I have
watched your video on letters for legacy
and I actually shared on my channel so a
few guys here might hopefully have seen
it too um but tell us a bit about
letters for legacy how you got involved
in it and what they're trying to do I've
just noticed your your Delvin in the
background by the way that's
amazing that's so much that all of it
all the shelvin brilliant I just did
that and I thought that took me
ages that's yeah this has been a project
yeah it looks cool right so you've got a
couple of Stargate faces up there as
well yeah I got bretac over there he was
at Star Trek convention in Vegas a
couple of years ago and got
him um yeah letters for
legacy I um I met the group that had
just formed uh August of last year at a
Star Trek convention shocker and um they
had a whole vendor table set up for
people to come and sign a letter to be
sent off to Tom Ryan who is the uh CEO
of streaming at Paramount plus that
basically lays out we would like Star
Trek Legacy we want seven of nine to be
captain and we want Terry metalis to run
the show thanks so much and that that
was pretty much it um and then uh Sean
sent in the letters for us and that
that's what we're doing is trying to do
a letter campaign a letter writing
campaign um because as much as we are
tweeting and uh Star Trek Legacy
hashtagging it everywhere we can it's
that tangible uh difference the
difference of holding it in your hand
500 a thousand letters from fans who
would really like to see Star Trek
Legacy and so that that's what it is
it's a letter writing campaign and
anyone can get
involved it's it's definitely makes a
difference because
um people like this in marketing and
stuff in
particular it's if when it's something
requires effort to do and you know
hashtag in Legacy that's great but it
doesn't really require any effort so
that helps them um so because because of
I I've very involved in I've been trying
to I talk a lot about Stargate and we're
trying to get Stargate to come back so
I've been learning about all these
different things
um and and how can we you know influence
Amazon and MGM to to bring back starget
for the love of God um and one of the
things is they um they rate things like
a letter writing thing higher because of
saying right well that fan is a is a and
they actually rate different fans so are
you an active fan or a um interested fan
or something else fan and they like
score it when they're doing these these
um method data that they like to do and
letters because it proves that the
person's writing the letter signing
letter go into the post box sign post
that requires
effort so that proves that you're an
active fan rather than just somebody
this goes hashtag Legacy yeah why not um
which is still important because we love
social media and they love social media
but um actually physically having to do
something is more
valuable so that's why it's important to
do um I I dropped the news a couple of
days ago um and we'll we'll we'll call
it a rumor for the sake of argument
because I don't want one but um the
Paramount of of had got basically have
this um working agreement now with um
Amazon to do a very similar deal to what
they did with
peard um I actually spoke to one guy who
said um as far as amaz is concerned
Legacy is just continuing be
they don't really see a difference so I
mean it's just like it's like theard
season 4 they're more than happy to
that's how they see it um and it'll be a
very similar deal parmount are happy
because they can't quite afford to make
Star Trek um Legacy um and that's they
going to be their business model for the
next five years anyway they' done it
with Prodigy they've done it with low
decks that's what they're going to do
um there was one addition to that though
whereas I've argued that actually it was
always going to happen Legacy was never
in doubt as far as I'm concerned um you
we still need to do these letters and
things because it still proves and
underlines the point but what do you
think about the point well my argument
basically is that they wouldn't have set
it up if they weren't going to do it
just like they set up strange new worlds
in Discovery season two and then they do
this big fan thing and then they can
pretend look we listen to the fans we
love you guys um
but really it was it's always the
plan I've actually got a video tomorrow
called the big Legacy the LI or explain
this all in a bit more detail
but what what do you think about that
think it's in
doubt I think I think I agree with you
that they are setting it up to to be a
show I think that uh metalis or whoever
else was involved as well set that up so
that there could be easily a spin-off
made of that final season I think that
intentions don't mean that it's reality
and that anything can go wrong
especially with
Paramount mergers and and issues that
could affect anything um and that if we
want to make sure that it's created
during all of this upheaval
business-wise that we have to continue
to make sure that they know that there's
a fan base waiting for it and the minute
we all go never mind we know that it's
going to be made we don't need to do
anything it's going to be the same as
sulu's exceler show or Captain warf's
show remember those shows weren't they
great how many seasons did they go
on zero they created I I know the Sulu
excelsia show nearly happened but I
don't think the warf show is ever
actually serious I know where Michael
dor kept talking about it but um I
that's the thing is you have so many
people who are prepared and ready to do
it if the fans aren't vocal about it
then then the the studios are not going
to give one care one way or the other
what we want
well yeah I I I always think that
there's this thing about oh that's just
fan service when did that become a bad
thing when did doing what the fans want
to become a bad
thing um that was one of the complaints
about Bard season 3 just fan service
yeah I'm a we appreciate it 30 years of
fandom man we been yeah we earned a
little fan service thank you very
much um lower deck is fun service yeah I
love it it's brilliant I love that when
they mention episodes of TNG and they
make jokes about T I love it um but yeah
I I think yeah there is a difference
between this being the
plan and then this being green lit and
that was one of the arguments when when
a couple of people jumped on my video
and should have said it's not in
development no never said it
was um I actually at the end of my video
say cautiously how I get new owners very
soon the chances are um you might get a
new manager coming and go we want to do
something completely different with Star
Trek um there are people at Paramount
according to one person I speak to that
wants want want them to do something
completely different with Star Trek um
the one person I spoke to says um they
there's a belief with some Executives at
Paramount that Star Trek has become
confusing that there's too many
timelines
um we've got the movies and the TV
series which are different universes and
us trekkies get it but like casual
viewers don't and they're like why is
everything different um it's like um and
and I can kind of Follow
that because I think there's that
there's that within the fan base there's
that
disagreement yeah there can be
especially when it comes to Canon
they're like well we they said
specifically that I don't know one
little thing 30 years ago and then they
show something different now and and
people get like really upset but I'm
pretty sure 30 years ago they didn't
predict that there were going to be a
whole bunch of new Star Trek shows and
that that one sentence was gonna throw
off a
storyline yeah I think there's a there's
a yeah I I think we can and I've argue
this loow time there is a line um
whereas because all right you're taking
the piss
now let's going too far um you the
romulans are good guys no no they've
always been sneaky um but you know that
that didn't happen but anyway um there
is a line with Canon but I also
think TNG messed up their own Cannon
more than once um and I'm like it was
fine it was normally done for like the
story or something was you know a
character did something that was out of
out of character for them and I'm like
yeah but it was for the
story there is a but but there is a line
but yes some people are nuts on it
that's the wrong bolt no calm down like
no um but also the change in technology
a load of people were really mad about
um Discovery and they said that doesn't
fit with the technology and I'm like
yeah but the original series they didn't
for even TNG did not foresee the
advancement in computer technology that
then happened over the last 20
years the computer core of the
Enterprise D it was
massive and remember the one episode
they were stooding it and it's like a
big oval it was huge and I'm like that's
um that would be a desktop
now um well in the Hightech uh how to
everybody had a laptop on Voyager and we
were supposed to think that that's
futuristic when we watch it now
Katherine Janeway has a laptop on her
desk in the ready
room yeah and it's a thick laptop too my
laptop's
thinner I like the little torches that
they had they used to H hold that sort
of thing and they were quite strong beam
and like oh that's futuristic and I'm
like no that's like my phone it's like
my phone's brighter than
that but yeah it is it oh it's true um
so I mean when they then have a new
series of um Discovery um or all strange
new worlds they have to upgrade the they
have to change some things because they
have to upgrade the technology because
certain things just look silly now um if
they didn't I mean okay we don't have
replicators but our our computer
technology is way more advanced than
what we saw in the original
sers I think they did that really well
on strange new worlds though they had a
deep respect for the original layout and
the color scheme and yeah it's all
upgraded and modernized for today but
you know we still have that red rail
that goes around and the captain's chair
is Central and I there was respect there
changes but respect yeah I would I would
definitely agree with that um that it it
felt like a fan had done it they they I
think by then though they'd had so much
grief about Canon I think they knew they
had to sort of make a bit it was almost
like they to make a bit more of it seems
to me that and I'm not going to come
down on Alex curtzman right because he's
not responsible for all of the evil in
the world and he just isn't mostly he's
just responsible
cling on but he obviously worked on the
JJ Abrams
movies um and he obviously he drew a lot
of that into the new series and trackies
like me hated it we could have accepted
the JJ Abrams movies because so well
it's a different universe so it's fine
um they look a bit different different
Universe
um but when they then dragged it into
the series we were like no no wait this
is the series
it's not a different Universe you can't
have Klingons that look like that and
and what happened to all the ships why
are all the ships weird looking and you
know it's like that sort of thing it's
so I think that's where people that's
where I got I started to get irritated
anyway so was like no you're dragging
stuff from the
movies um and I love the films but
they're not Star Trek for me they're
they're good
Sci-Fi movies and I like them but
start um they just have a few similar
names I I enjoyed the first one the
first not reboot but going off on
another timeline the curtzman timeline I
I enjoyed the first one I disliked
second and third one I I I was like
that's not con and the third one was
just I don't know it was seems like it
was halfhazard LE put together in my
opinion the story itself I just didn't
enjoy those other two I didn't mind the
third one particularly but it it felt a
bit like um
Star Trek always does these like you
know there's the um odd even movie
problem other
than other than um in the first couple
of films they were like good film crap
film good it felt like Insurrection to
me it felt like you know it's like it's
okay but it's like they're not really
taking it seriously and there are
elements of this film that this fil make
no sense like Star base um what was it
star base it wasn't Z1 was it was the
Starbase no
um no I it was it was a weird one though
is the thing is had a name didn't
it um but then I had all these biodomes
and stuff I'm like why why is the tunnel
big enough for the Enterprise to fly
through all the way through the
base under the river wh why would they
build that they just build side and so I
just think that makes no f freaking
sense at all but um but but again I like
parts of it parts of the film are pretty
good um it's just KH in the second
one can't and I like Cumberbatch don't
get me wrong but he's not KH well the
thing is I think you I think um Benedict
kumat is a great actor and you have to
work really hard to make him look like
such a crap actor so from that point of
view I think they did really well York
town thank you sir it was the it was
Starbase yor
well done um you get a prize ah yes
there thank you that's a that's a Sean
who is one of our fearless leaders for
letters for
legacy yeah well got a price uh cake
Star Trek cake or something I'm
advertising Legacy though so it's good
oh I've just turned off the Legacy thing
oh go all the way back through now and
find
it oh got loads of people commenting so
I might just have to write it again I've
lost it never mind I'll write it again
um yeah I ior isn't
it new comments boom there we go right
um but yeah I I'm I they keep talking
about where they're going to get another
movie and um the the most recent thing
I'm hearing is that we're probably not
um but we might get this prequel movie
that they want to do I was like oh for
love of God um the cake is not a lie he
just said the cake is a lie it's not a
lie I never
lie it's just that I'm gonna eat the
cake before I send it I'll buy it though
um there will be
cake it'll just go in my belly um but
yeah but so so to go to Legacy
then how important do you think because
I mean we've got Star Trek Academy
coming I think it's fair to say the fan
base are mixed on
Academy um I agree I yeah I keep calling
it Star Trek 9210 and I'm it started off
as a joke but um I feel I feel a bit
disrespectful now but I will give it a
try
um but fans are excited about Legacy I
think we're pretty much United that
we're desperate for
legacy yeah anybody I have spoken to
been very excited about um uh the
prospect of a show where seven is the
captain where Terry is uh the showrunner
people have a great respect for both of
them um Jerry for playing such a a a
layered character that has developed
incredibly over her run and then Terry
with his history with Star Trek is quite
frankly the only one I would want
heading the show because you know he's
going to respect where it's come from
and be excited about bringing things
forward and pushing it along to wherever
it's gonna go well I mean I watched him
in the interview on the shuttle pod show
and his love for Star Trek was not
subtle um when he was sort of like he it
was as the email he sent to his um agent
was um subject Star main body of the
thing Trek that's all I want to do um
get me on that damn show um and so so
yeah and I and I think he did a
wonderful job even though I did get into
an argument with him on Twitter
accidentally once when I said I hated
the Borg in season two so he he wasn't
very happy with me and I I said I'm
sorry but I didn't like it but um I just
love the the third season I I watched it
again um about a month ago just and I
still got giggly when the Enterprise D
came out we all knew that was coming oh
yes we all knew that it was so obvious
from like the second episode that that's
what was going to
happen it it was great yeah it still
made me
[Music]
go um there's a there's a I did though I
did have a joke somebody said um there's
a TV show over here called only fs and
horses did you ever get that in the US
much I have not heard no yeah so the one
of the jokes there was this one guy
trigger and he's a bit of an idiot um
and he was a road sweep that was his job
he used to sweep the roads and he was
getting an award because he' managed to
keep the same brush for like 20 years
and they were like trig how' you do that
goes well it's maintenance you see I've
had nine new handles and 12 new brush
heads I'm like oh it's not the same
brush then trick something so that was
the joke that he'd actually not had the
same brush so and that when the
Enterprise D came out I did think that
kind of the same because it's not really
the D
um it's it's a bit of a d another ship
attached but I still
went yeah I I I cried I'm not gonna lie
I was like there they are they're all
the fridge
I yeah um I love the bit when they um
again again they had the humor in there
that I absolutely loved the joke about
um Warf I'd love I I we desperately need
to find out what happened to the D um
they cannot just leave that joke sat
there they've got to explain that um and
then um and then when they're all on
there and they have that sentimental
moment and that was really this is again
I think why Terra matal is such a good
writer and such a good you know maker TV
maker that doesn't sound right but um
they're having that sentimental moment
you know and they're ready there to to
it could have got cheesy that could it
could have got silly
but then wolf just makes the comment I
prefer the weapons on the D and the E
and um and then they go W that's very
good to be back so I think that it was
just that cut through the cheese you
know and it's like I I just thought that
was absolutely brilliant um
yeah I'm just hoping we go on no no I
was GNA say Warf and data in their own
ways always seem to bring humor and you
would they're least likely to bring
humor and yet they are always the ones
who bring the humor and H yeah that
that's all I had to say about well yeah
I didn't actually think data data was
always my favorite character I didn't
actually like I didn't love him in in
Bard season three
um I I thought they could have used him
better but war was perfect it was done
absolutely perfectly and Brent Spiner is
still one of my favorite actors I watch
everything he does on YouTube and the
man is mental I love him um but it
didn't quite work and the bit where he's
sort of like um flying through the Bard
Cube I didn't love that but
um and it's said why am I sensing joy
and then it goes to his face and he's
like he's flying through the I have to
admit I did did amuse me um but yeah um
it's Warf was perfect all the way
through he absolutely perfect and his
relationship with rafy just cracked me
up as well I just thought it was great
yeah um I know rafy is not the most
popular character in the world but I
think it's not fair I think there idiots
out there that think rafy
because
um they said characters too veriable I'm
like that's she's a really good actress
I don't know what they're on about
but unfortunately we get
big next to seven I think she's probably
the most honest character because she
wasn't just molded Starfleet and that's
all she's ever been she Starfleet she
had problems she's had family problems
she's had substance problems and then
she comes back and and Starfleet gives
her that second chance I think that you
know like her like seven like row um
she's a great character for for Star War
for Star Wars for Star
Wars Star
Wars I got them on the wall too I can
whoever I want I got Star Wars Star Trek
Star Star Gate I'm good yeah I did a
video a couple of weeks ago I say no I'm
not the biggest Star Wars fan if
somebody did go um you've got a massive
X-Ring right behind
you oh yeah sorry I might have be
talking I might be saying things just to
cause an argument I don't know I do that
sometimes
um but yeah um so where do you think
we're going then do you think Legacy on
our screens next next
year I guessing don't know if I would
say next year I would say that if we
keep fighting the good fight and
Paramount sticks to the projects that
they have uh in the burner right now
between the the peard movie The possible
fourth movie that's a prequel and uh
section 31 which is you know in in
progress of being filmed
now I think it would be more like
2026 but I think it's a very high Poss
posibility if we just keep asking for it
and it doesn't get lost in all of the
business decisions that Paramount's gon
to be making that's the
problem that's the unknown entity is is
what who's going to come in and who is
going to invest but if they continue
doing what they've been basically doing
of filming pretty much constantly
whereas they they they ended strange new
worlds filming within a month or so oh
the strikes have sort of messed things
up a bit bit but um they started the
section 31 movie filming they're
planning to start filming Academy almost
straight after that um I think we could
get this in 2026 if they but if we do
we'll get the
announcement April and if if if if we
haven't had Announcement by then it
won't
happen yeah too long because I mean we
had the academy announcement and it's at
least a year until it's going to be well
it's been a year now hasn't it I think
it'll be another year we can't count the
strike
time yeah yeah we got to basically
remove nine months of that but um from
announcement to screens 18 months I
think is
reasonable
um but yeah Zach Winfield Star Trek day
and I think is that's in April isn't it
I think um they should announc it on May
the 4th just to wind Star Wars fans up
that's what I would do well if they
don't do it by then they're going to
have to to wait until what
ComiCon yeah which is a while they don't
tend to do that anymore they do they
they tend to um they tend to announce
things just with like a statement and
and now it seems to be nowadays and then
they get all the actors on stage for the
Comic Con that seems to be how they do
it nowadays I think they've got to a
point where they realize they just can't
keep anything secret anymore so it's
like we have to announce it or
they just they just won't or some idiot
Like Me on YouTube will tell everybody
anyway I think that's how we found out
Paul Wesley was going to be back on
season two a strange New World somebody
captured pictures of him in Canada in
full garb running around with LA and
people are like well something's
happening here yeah he's back yeah
that's how we knew and well that's how
we found out he was going to be kir
wasn't it pretty much because we'd sell
the photos from season two and like he's
goingon to be because they filmed it
back toback didn't they season one and
two yeah so I was thought that was so
weird I like right so he's um so that
they're screwing with Cannon
again I keep joking that um Paul Wesley
and Kirk they um he's he's running out
of excuses to go to the Enterprise now
it's going to be like I've got my keys
so I'm back on the Enterprise again um
the last time he was there it was like
I've got some training thing they didn't
even really bother explaining it there
like
I'm just here
sh don't mention it they might play off
the laan Kirk relationship for a little
while as an excuse to bring him back
every now and then oh I'm here to visit
an old friend laan how you doing and you
know then they get sucked into a Time
Warp and something
again again Katie I'm sorry I've got to
make a run because um I'm expected
on so um I'm going to go over on to I'll
be on mbed in a second talking with a
young
American about uh about Paramount
actually I think at least in part okay
um but yeah I've absolutely love
chatting here hopefully we can do it
again soon and particularly if we get an
announcement on Legacy um or when I
don't know what's the next Star Trek
thing coming out actually we haven't got
anything have we um we're waiting for
discovering an April um I'm thinking
that lower decks will be out this summer
and then section 31 this fall so strange
new worlds probably not till
2025 nothing that I know for sure just
guesses Discovery I tell you what I will
I will put my hand on I will promise I
will watch Discovery if you come back
and have a chat with us about it but it
might be a video of me going I wish I'd
made this promise this is stupid promise
I hate this stupid
show but you can try to be the the voice
of
positivity okay that's what I do I'm
here to to spread positivity um if you
don't mind I Al want to just remind
people to go check out letters for
legacy um if you visit my channel you'll
see that I'm running a little GoFundMe
to try to get myself to another
convention where I can go gather more if
you want to help me out I appreciate
that and um thanks for letting me come
and talk about Legacy and kind of
straighten out the the what's going
on I I love I will always I I just love
having different people on the the the
the video and you know having someone to
talk to and um I always said that the
best thing about YouTube is the people
you meet and um I've made genuine
friends through YouTube um not Harrison
stormmy they can all they can both you
for my my guys will know stormy's got um
he's he's our old America we call him
the resident American and he's got um
he's got quite a nasty um infection in
his bone in his leg it's really nasty um
um so obviously I immediately went you
got an infection in your boner and then
just just literally no no
sympathy no they just mock him
mercilessly for it um but luckily our
stormy is on the menend now he is
getting better and hopefully be back on
our lives soon um I didn't even know you
could get an infection in the bone
so um but he's on the
menend Katie thank you so so much we
will see you when Discovery comes out I
will make you come
back all right there's a threat that I
can probably live up
to thank you so so much and guys
everyone in the comments thank you again
uh you've been brilliant as always we'll
see you really really
soon see bye Katie bye Katie